I've talked to lots of business people about leadership and there's a literature
on leadership,
but it's not a good literature.
It's,
it's pretty shallow.
Um,
partly because it's not that easy to define leadership and partly because there
are different,
you know,
people have different temperaments and different temperaments can be leaders.
They just do it in different ways.
Now there's something in common about being a leader.
The,
and I would say one is that if you're a natural leader,
you actually know where you're going,
right?
Cause what are you going to do lead people in circles.
It's like maybe they'll follow you but you're not a leader.
You're just a charlatan.
So you have to know where you're going and then you have to be able to
communicate that and then people have to trust you.
So you actually have to be honest,
cause people aren't that stupid.
At least not for a long period of time.
And then where are you going?
Has to have some value because otherwise,
why would anyone want to go along with you?
So,
and then you might say,
well what,
what are the attributes then that make you a leader?
And I would say well they're characterological fundamentally and this is not
naive optimism or,
or or casual demoralizing.
It has nothing to do with that.
You know,
we know for example that conscientious that the personality trait is a good
predictor of long term success in in most occupations,
not all but most.
And that one of the things that's associated with conscientiousness is that
people keep their word,
they're trustworthy.
And that's certainly one element of a leader,
especially across any reasonable amount of time.
You have to be able to trust the person.
They can even be harsh,
right?
It doesn't matter because you can see harsh leaders and kind leaders,
but as long as they do what they say they will do and then you can follow them
and you know that the future payoff is,
is,
is secure,
something like that.
So the idea that character,
logical development is more important to leadership then primogenitor I think
that's the right word.
Ah,
premo genesis anyways,
being a first born,
that's a very crucial psychological realization that its character,
logical development that makes you favored of God.
You know?
And I do think we've forgotten this in many ways because there isn't a lot of
emphasis in our education system on characterological development.
And that's very,
very surprising to me.
I think maybe it's partly because in our fractured society,
we can't agree on what constitutes a reasonable character,
a logical goal.
So we just throw up our hands and don't educate our kids to any degree at all,
especially in schools about what an admirable person is like,
or even let them know that,
well,
maybe you should actually try to be one.
You know that that's actually the most important possible thing that you could
learn.